>> Tucker: DAVID SPUNT LIFE IN
WASHINGTON.
MICHAEL CAPUTO IS A FORMER
ADVISOR TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
2016 AND HE'S BEEN THROUGH THE
RINGER IN THE LAST COUPLE YEARS.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
MICHAEL, YOU WATCH THE
SENTENCING, THE SECOND ROUND OF
SENTENCING FOR PAUL MANAFORT
TODAY AND YOU SAW THAT ONE OF
THE CHARGES TO THE BLED TO WAS
NOT REGISTERING AS A FOREIGN
AGENT REGISTRATION ACT OF
1938.
SOMETHING THAT BASICALLY NOBODY
IN WASHINGTON DOES.
DID YOU BEGIN TO WONDER MAYBE IF
THIS WAS A SELECTIVE
PROSECUTION?
>> [LAUGHS]
WOW.
YEAH, I GUESS SO.
TUCKER, NOBODY KNOWS MORE THAN
YOU THAT THE LEFT VIEWS ABSOLUTE
ANNIHILATION THIS VICTORY.
THEY WILL STOP AT NOTHING TO
ACHIEVE IT.
THEY WILL TRY TO GET YOU FIRED,
TRY TO SILENCE YOU OR THEY WILL
TRY, LIKE IN MY FAMILY, TRY TO
RUIN YOUR FAMILY OR EVEN THROW
YOUR DAD IN JAIL.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME, PAUL
MANAFORT IS GOING TO JAIL FOR
REGISTERING
REGISTRATION CHARGE AND HIS
PARTNER ON THE UKRAINE PROJECT
WHERE HE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
BREAKING THE LAW IS TONY
PODESTA.
AS FAR AS WE CAN TELL, TONY
PODESTA HASN'T BEEN INDICTED.
SO EVEN A BLIND PERSON CAN SEE
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
>> Tucker: MAY I STOP YOU
THERE?
WAS TONY PODESTA REGISTERED
UNDER THE FOREIGN AGENT
REGISTRATION ACT OF 1938?
I DON'T THINK HE WAS.
>> HE WAS NOW.
WHEN MANAFORT WAS CALLED ON IT,
SO WAS TONY AND THEY BOTH KIND
OF A CONTEMPORANEOUS REGISTERED
FOR IT AND THEY THOUGHT THAT WAS
FINE FOR TONY BUT I GUESS HE
DIDN'T LOOK TOO GOOD FOR PAUL
MANAFORT.
YOU KNOW, IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
AND NOW THAT WE SEE LISA PAGE'S
TESTIMONY EVERYTHING THAT'S
BECOMING MORE CLEAR THAN WE EVER
IMAGINED IT WOULD BECOME, LOOK,
THE MUELLER REPORT IS SUPPOSED
TO BE COMING TO A CLOSE.
MY FAMILY HAS HAD OUR LIVES ON
PAUSE FOR TWO YEARS, ALONG WITH
DOZENS OF OTHER FAMILIES.
81 OTHER PEOPLE LEARNED THIS
WEEK OR LAST WEEK THAT IT WASN'T
OVER IN THE HOUSE EITHER.
CHAIRMAN NADLER APPEARS TO BE
STARTING IT ALL OVER AGAIN AND
ASKED US OFFER DOCUMENTS.
IT APPEARS THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
A LONG, LONG SUMMER WITH 81
PEOPLE BEING MARCHED IN FRONT OF
THE HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
>> Tucker: ARE YOU GOING BACK?
>> I WON'T GO BACK.
I GAVE THEM A QUICK ANSWER, ME
AND MY ATTORNEY, WE HAVE NO
DOCUMENTS THAT THEY ASKED FOR.
I ALSO HAVE THE SHORTEST
DOCUMENT REQUEST OF ALL 81
PEOPLE.
BUT THEY STILL ASKED MY ATTORNEY
IF HE WOULD PRESENT ME FOR
TESTIMONY.
IF THEY ARE INVITING ME, THEY
ARE INVITING ALL OF US.
LISTEN, AT THE END OF THE DAY,
TUCKER, WE HAVE TALKED SEVERAL
TIMES ABOUT THIS.
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR TWO
YEARS AND IT'S A LONG DANCE.
I TESTIFIED THREE TIMES UNDER
OATH.
EACH TIME TO THE SAME QUESTIONS,
EACH TIME IT COST ME HALF A
YEAR'S SALARY, AND HERE WE GO
AGAIN JUST FOR MY FAMILY WAS
WAITING TO PRESS PLAY ON OUR
LIVES, RIGHT?
I'VE GOT NOTHING LEFT.
THEY'VE TAKEN MY BUSINESS.
THEY HAVE PUNCH THE LIVING CRAP
OUT OF MY FAMILY.
I'VE GOT NOTHING LEFT.
WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO TAPE UP
MY FREEDOM AND THE ONLY WAY
THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE MY FREEDOM
AS IF I TESTIFY A FOURTH TIME
UNDER OATH AND THEY GET -- THEY
TEAR ME APART LIKE DEMOCRATS ARE
WONT TO DO.
I'M NOT WILLING TO DO THAT, SO
I'LL TAKE THE FIFTH.
AND I WILL KEEP DOING IT AS LONG
AS MY FAMILY'S GO FUND ME HOLDS
OUT.
ON GO FUND ME.COM I THINK SOME
OF THE OTHER 81 PEOPLE SHOULD DO
IT AS WELL.
YOUR NETWORK STOOD BEHIND YOU
AND I'M HOPING PEOPLE STAND
BEHIND ME.
>> Tucker: I GUESS THE LESSON
IS YOU SHOULD'VE WORKED FOR JEB
OR JOHN KASICH.
I DON'T SEE THE FEDS GOING AFTER
ANYBODY WHO WORKED ON THE JOB!
CAMPAIGN OR JOHN KASICH.
I'M SURE IT'S NOT CONNECTED.
>> JEB TOOK MONEY FROM THE
CHINESE, OVER MILLION DOLLARS.
I DON'T SEE ANYBODY ASKING ABOUT
THAT BUT HERE WE GO AGAIN WITH
THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION DELUSION.
YOU SAW YESTERDAY CHAIRMAN
SCHIFF WHO IS MISSING ALL THE
HEADLINES IN THE CAMERA TIME, HE
IS SAYING IF MUELLER'S REPORT
DOESN'T COME IN AND HAS THE
PRESIDENT TWEETING SOME QUESTION
AND ANSWER WITH MUELLER, HE'S
GOING TO START OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
ALL HE IS SAYING IS IF YOU DON'T
RELEASE THE MUELLER REPORT,
WE'RE GOING TO TEAR EVERYBODY
APART LIMB FROM LIMB.